david la situation était tendue tout à
l'heure où est-ce qu'on en laisse et
bien écoutez à ce filet l'opération
blocage s'est mise en place petit à
petit ici un devant l'incinérateur
d'ivry organisé par l as et gts qui est
assez fou on sait que des soudeurs ont
mis des poteaux en métal sur les grilles
et les ont fixé un pour bloquer l'accès
aux camions et bloqué l'accès aux dépôts
d'ordures ménagères ce qui va affluer
des plus en plus dans la capitale
parisienne pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée
ses 3000 tonnes de déchets par jour dans
la capitale parisienne que que les
usagers utilisent au quotidien
ils sont à peu près 150 6 610
syndicaliste a bloqué l'accès à cet
incinérateur les forces de l'ordre se
sont mises en place nous on était un peu
submergé pris par surprise par le nombre
de manifestants qui se sont rendus ici
devant l'incinérateur d'ivry
vous l'avez dit c'est une réunion
interprofessionnelle des élus également
locaux sont sur place je vous propose
d'écouter mais à des la maire adjointe
d'yves riches comme dans les dépôts la
ratp comme auprès des enseignants comme
auprès des personnels de santé comme
auprès des territoriaux je crois que la
place des élus de gauche aujourd'hui et
dans les luttes et avec les
travailleuses et les travailleurs pour
défendre leurs droits pour une retraite
digne
la france est dans la rue tous azimuts
toutes professions confondues et qu'on
est face à un mur qui ne veut pas
écouter les revendications légitimes
du peuple de france qui veut vivre mieux
dans meilleures conditions et c'est pas
du tout ce que le gouvernement nous
proposons l'objectif principal de ce
blocage de l'incinérateur d'ivry est
évidemment le retrait de la réforme des
retraites à l'appel
ld interprofessionnelle il y à du
personnel hospitalier du personnel de la
ratp a des soudeurs des gaziers
également un qui sont présents ici pour
répondre à cet appel de la cgt avec un
objectif clair toujours le même
évidemment le retrait de la réforme des
retraites merci beaucoup aux david un
califat